1000 baht und kleinem wohlfühl bäuchlein
so sieht corona quarantäne bei max
gladiator russell crowe aus der 56
jährige lebt derzeit völlig isoliert auf
einem anwesen im australischen outback
mit dabei sein 84-jähriger vater
erinnern uns geht es ziemlich gut ich
habe festgestellt dass ich mich in den
letzten 30 jahren ehe von allem isoliert
habe und dass ich ziemlich gut darin bin
hier im busch ist die bevölkerungsdichte
nicht wirklich hoch wahrscheinlich ist
das schlimmste für mich an einem von
meinen kindern getrennten ort isoliert
zu sein denn fürn arsch apples board
markiert sie leben mit ihrer mutter in
sydney und es ist so ungewöhnlich für
mich so lange zu hause zu sein und sie
nicht zu sehen aber sie wollten in der
stadt bleiben und ich bin im busch zu
sehen ist der oscar-gewinner im juli im
psycho thriller anhin ist außer
kontrolle
dort spielt er einen psychopathischen
autofahrer der plötzlich durchdreht und
eine frau terrorisiert
da hat mein handy gestoßen
ich sitze hier und warte auf dich wessen
handy ist das zusammen mit einem freund
[Musik]
ihre erste lektion beginnt jetzt ein
neuer film wurde mehrfach verschoben
man kann also gerade nichts planen mein
nächster film soll ab oktober in der
dominikanischen republik gedreht werden
und ich soll eigentlich sehr bald einen
anderen film in amerika abdrehen
aber die australischen grenzen sind noch
dicht keiner von uns weiß wie die nahe
zukunft aussehen würde
in der future sein nächstes reiseziel
könnte berlin werden hier will der 56
jährige mit seiner band auftreten wenn
corona es zulässt